you've been to so many places what's a  lifestyle not their own life miserable  you're either sunburned sleep-deprived  or seasick and after a few days there's  that loosen Asians why do you do it it's  a fear it's intense fish you and the  infinite horizon we must be a sailor - I  take it I don't know that I would  consider myself a sailor oh come on not  you you are you want to take her out  hmm anytime you think you might want to  go sailing  [Music]  how would you like to sail it as Ana to  California verse four thousand miles is  insane I'm sailing with me  [Music]  Hurricane Raymond has been upgraded to a  category 5  I love you  [Music]  [Applause]  we're not gonna die out here  you  you